- What's up, y'all, I'm back
with world-famous musicians
and least predictable
combination, Little Big Town
and Machine Gun Kelly.
Give it up for 'em.
(crowd cheering)
I feel like it's that show
crossroads, CMT crossroads,
where you don't, y'all
should do crosswords.
- Yes, yes.
- I just dated us. We're all old.
Okay, it's our week-long
tribute to music everybody.
It's time to get to know these
guys a little better with,
what else?
A little game.
Many of us have heard of
the game, marry, shag, kill,
where you name three people
and assign one of those
actions to each person,
and it always gets
awkward on the shag one.
It's time for a game
of wine, beer, whiskey.
(upbeat music)
♪ Wine, beer, whiskey ♪
♪ Well, well ♪
Sing a song.
In this game, I'll give each
person a list of three people.
It's their job to say
who'd they drink wine with,
who'd be a good beer buddy
and who they'd pick to join them
as they hit the bottle of
whiskey, and of course,
why they chose these people
for those specific things.
So let's start with Karen.
Wine, beer, whiskey.
Your options are Cher,
Dolly Parton, Blake Shelton.
- Well, oh my gosh. All would be amazing.
Cher, I'm going to say wine. Dolly, beer.
And because I have personal
experience with this,
Blake and whiskey.
- (laughs) Me too.
It doesn't end well.
Phillip's turn. Phillip, this is you.
Wine, beer, whiskey.
Rascal Flatts, Luke
Bryan and Blake Shelton.
- Okay, so I'm going to
go wine with Rascal Flatts
because that'd be a little
more chill, beer with Luke,
'cause we've had experience with Luke,
having slept on my bus one night on tour
and then Blake with whiskey
because when he's buzzed
like that, he's so happy
and he always gives me hugs.
- Let's get some hugs.
Oh my God, that's awesome.
I always love, I feel
like Blake always gets
that old man laugh.
It's like the...
- Yes.
- It's like that really old man laugh,
like what's happening?
That's awesome.
I really, at some point in
time, if we can't share it here,
just in life, I want to
hear the Luke Bryan story
at some point.
Okay, Machine Gun Kelly, you're next.
Wine, beer whiskey.
Pete Davidson, Dave
Chappelle, Celine Dion,
which is awesome. (laughs)
- That's so tight.
- Great choices.
- Those are the best choices.
- Beer with Pete, 'cause
that's what we already do.
Dave Chappelle, I've had a
night out with Dave and Pete.
He flew us on his jet to just
chill with him for a night.
- Wow, I want friends like that.
- We went to his mom, we
landed and he was like,
"Oh, forgot, we've got to go
to my mom's 81st birthday party,"
went there, then after that, he was like,
"Do you guys want to
hang for a little bit?"
I'm like, "I've got a concert."
He's like, "You guys
will be back by tomorrow
"for the concert, it's all good."
And then he had little
outposts throughout the town
with man-cave, with bars
with whiskey and tequila,
so we just went to all these men caves,
and then I got on a jet
and went to a concert,
and then I woke up
after that and was like,
"What's going on here?"
- I love that.
- And then me and Pete took
my daughter on a road trip
to New York and spent
Christmas at his mom's house.
The weirdest two days in my life.
- I love your life.
This should be a movie.
Even the fact that you ended up
in an 81 year old woman's birthday party.
I just love the combination of all that.
That's amazing. Okay.
Well, Kimberly, you're up.
Wine, beer, whiskey.
Taylor Swift, Martina McBride, and well,
we'll just do Shelton, 'cause
we know he likes to drink.
- I'm going to say beer with Taylor.
Wine with Martina
McBride, which I've done.
She loves her wine and I'm going
to have to save the whiskey
for Blake, and I'll have to tell you,
there was a day when I had to
make peanut butter sandwiches
for one of us
because she had too many
whiskies with somebody.
- (laughs) It's dangerous.
I tell all people to not drink,
never drink with Blake
Shelton or Ronnie Dunn.
You will be screwed.
- I want to drink with Blake Shelton
and eat peanut butter sandwiches now.
- I want to see you drinking
and having peanut butter jelly sandwiches,
going to 81 year old birthday
parties with Blake Shelton.
This is an episode I'm
willing to fight for.
And, finally, Jimmy.
Wine, beer, whiskey.
Thomas Rhett, University
of Alabama football coach,
Nick Saban, and what the hell?
We'll just keep Shelton,
'cause people like him here.
- All right, I would have
a beer with Thomas Rhett.
He's just that kind of dude.
He's the guy you want
to go have a beer with.
I would say a glass of
whiskey with Nick Saban,
'cause I think that would be
one of those conversations
where you sit and just sip on the whiskey
and take in his knowledge.
I just want to hear what he has to say.
That seems like that
would work over whiskey.
And I would say wine with Blake,
because that would be
the least obvious choice,
and I think it would be hilarious,
trying to have a refined
wine conversation.
- (laughs) That's awesome.
- It maybe also would be fun.
- That's awesome.
Thank you guys for playing,
even though you had no choice.
(laughs)